it's kind of
sick oh
oh yeah
looking fancy smancy and
ball
yeah i'm at a party
i just got planted
at the party
oh god
i can't do this
water
just gotta grab some water that's all
right thank you
i will grab the water now
you know how it is right
you try to
watch it
i'm just trying to grab the water can i
get some help here excuse me
can i get some water
someone please help me what she fell she
must be dehydrated let me give her some
water
no no it's okay listen i understand i
understand how it looked like what
happened here listen officer i can ex i
can explain
it wasn't me
all right i'm sorry i gotta kill
witnesses it's nothing person though
is i'm so sorry
but you saw my face and now i have to
kill you you understand oh you look so
horrified don't look so sad
listen listen
you looked at my face
sorry i'm so sorry
it's a big misunderstanding this i'm
just the guy
trying to pardon me there we go
i'm just a guy
trying to blend in
into a party
i'm just trying to be
confused okay
i'm not very good at stealth games i
gotta be honest with you guys i'll just
try this again hey
that's all right i'm not thirsty but
thank you anyway
[Music]
on behalf of his royal highness omar al
ghazali i beat you welcome to this
morning
thank you
you don't find this awkward
no
no this is normal here yeah let me shake
your head
okay that's right that's fine let's just
say let's just blend in at the
at the party
all right here we go oh drinks
complimentary
thank you
oh yes
thank you oh you have another one
that's okay
that's okay
oh sorry i didn't mean that
stop
[Applause]
how do you do that
whoa
that's awesome all right i gotta blend
in backstage
hello guys
how are we
oh an apple don't mind if i do i want an
apple a baby
you know they say an apple
i'm just gonna grab an apple if that's
all right with everyone i'm just gonna
grab this apple is that okay with you
you want the apple
how about you you want that you're all
okay with me who's gonna grab this apple
you never know we need an apple right
anyway this is nice talking to you guys
i'll see you this part is weird
everyone's weird they think i'm weird i
bet they all think i'm super weird i see
another fellow blending
but you look natural just like me we
have the same swagger
how you doing lady
you know you look just like my grandma
excuse me
are these new shoes
she's [ __ ] vaping
[Music]
all right where's the server room does
anyone have you guys seen the server
room i'm not trying to hack that
they got freakings
coins
free money
this is awesome
don't mind if i do let me tell you
something i'll tell you something man
you look uh
you look like a handsome man i think you
can let me go through
i just need to talk to you sir okay i'm
gonna go
no you don't need to talk to me
i didn't do anything i'm innocent if he
said if he said i touched him he touched
me first i'm going to the toilet now
that was close i'm going to overflow the
sink
the sink
the sink is overflowing
[Music]
yeah
okay so i can disguise as them now
nice
yes
i like this
don't go in the bathroom guys
it smells like someone had a
gas
nuclear explosion and i am normal i'm
drinking soda
i'm working at the bar
just cutting some lime
hey server boy wait a minute
if anyone comes near me i'm gonna
[ __ ] shank them okay
they better not with me
i told you bro oh this is a battle now
bro i shot you
how many are there
all right maybe i failed maybe i failed
but you know what i stubbed the guy in
the dick and that was pretty cool
new strat i'm not even going to try to
blend in
yeah
[Applause]
why why is everyone running now
i'm just a party guy i'm not even a part
of the guy stop y'all [ __ ] up you didn't
see nothing [ __ ] you
don't run from me
go squeal
what did i do i'm a normal guy i'm a
normal guy at a party i don't get it i'm
just a
just a guy vlogging i'm a vlogger what's
up guys uh i'm at the party in dubai
this is so cool i'm meeting all kinds of
cool people here i'm making all kinds of
friends here at this party
women love me and they don't fear me at
this party here's one right here how are
you doing
say what i mean totally normal hey
hey isn't this so cool with all the
cubes yeah i know right that's so cool
put down put down the ipad listen to me
listen to me put down the empire
okay thank you no put down the ipad put
down the effect stop it stop it put down
the ipad just put it down i'm talking to
you put that on the ipad stop
i'll tickle you
are gonna put that in the ipad
are you gonna put down the airplane are
you gonna put down the ipad are you
going to put down the ipad
oh my
[Music]
oh yours
i'm gonna have to stop her
she's gonna tell someone
right
i'm gonna disguise myself as a
technician okay so what if i take these
out at the same time
they don't seem to mind that i'm here
actually what are you some kind of thief
you can't be it
[Laughter]
all right ladies let's go
wow
oh
what's going on listen i can explain
what happened all right it's a funny
story
we're doing good okay so now i go up the
ladder
obviously
hello
am i says am i says sir you are trying
to say this all right
i'm taking you in hands up here
am i
okay so now i can be penthouse guard
nice and then can i throw them off
because i think i feel like that's
easier to deal with like it's a little
horrible but
oh my god i can
i
i think he might live actually where did
the other guy go
okay so maybe like i can hack the
helicopter hey man
what's going on
oh oh oh
oh oh
oh
oh
yes
yes turn around
okay so if i turn off the fuse box
oh they're gonna come in and investigate
it and i'm gonna be hiding here
in the shadows
hey good night
and you're
off
baby gosh you're gonna go in there
that's perfect back to me
i am the rest i am the replacement guy
here i am waste my time it's me oh he's
the guy i'm supposed to kill
oh okay perfect
okay blend in
i'm blending in
all right we're going to take you out
sorry hey how you doing you're doing
great
oh i actually did it
i did it
okay let's just pull him away
oh
why are you dragging that poor person
around i'm not he's dragging himself
actually
he found the pile all right let's find
him he was close
let's grab a water bottle first i'm
thirsty
maybe next time brownies
i am the assassin ass
assassination
oh
why am i not supposed to be we tolerate
no trespasses
i tolerate no rants
you're coming with
me hell
why does your body make that sound bro
[Music]
we got another one for the pow boys
another one back
yeah
oh
they're all sleeping it's okay it's like
pokemon oh i'm a penthouse banana
assassination
don't do it
don't murder them
shut up banana you don't know me like i
know myself you're supposed to step in
this game feelings not to scare everyone
shut the [ __ ] up banana you don't know
me banana
felix you've been doing this talking to
inanimate objects and video games for
like years now when are you gonna shut
up
yeah
i release the
oh i killed someone
you're a cold-blooded murderer shut the
[ __ ] banana i didn't know that was gonna
die it was an accident it could have
happened to anyone i'm trying my best
i'm going to the toilet now
i'm going gonna give you washed banana
okay there you go maybe i'll teach you
to cool down banana oh [ __ ]
oh they got these japanese toilet
bananas check this out
that's awesome oh my god
maybe this
all right i need to do my job don't do
it felix
shut up banana it's fine
don't hurt him he's innocent
[Music]
shut the [ __ ] up
don't look at me like that banana
[Music]
us banana
the pile woke up are you kidding me
that's ridiculous i guess i will have to
do
that's the only way i can trust you guys
hey man i was just walking around and i
was
just checking in who this banana belongs
to
nothing personal kiddo
don't want the pile to wake up again
yes look how far we come banana
look how far we can
what's that
you can't stop me banana i'm on a
mission
do i know you i don't know you yes you
do
yes you do here we go
here we go
oh my god we can hack the system guys
hey what are you doing here
we're good
i did
it it how many more innocent people will
have today felix
bananas
you must be my new escort yes yes that's
me i have very high standards give me a
hug
you have your credentials on you of
course here we go oh wait sorry that's
my banana uh
there we go
all right let's just blend in the
security guard i'm blending in security
guy
uh this is my friend banana
don't blow your cover bin in it show me
what you got
[Music]
[Music]
oh i'm lit
good
i think so too
what to do with all that power
banana
banana
banana
you see that banana 47
now we just gotta find the last guy the
banana i mean it's a meme but like it's
actually a really good weapon because
what happens in the game is that it's
not seen as a lethal and a weapon so you
can just see
you know what i mean let's make sure
they don't wake up
can i blend in here
i blend in here nice stephon
whoops what was that what was that
yeah all right
he's got to be here somewhere there you
go carl ingraham
a swedish looking guy
there he is
hold up
banana
mission
yes
that's what i'm talking about the banana
session
they said it couldn't be done
smash like let me tell you why opera gx
is the greatest browser that everyone
should be using first off gx control if
your computer runs like this
or seems like it's running inside that
here then just slap on gx control which
lets you limit the amount of ram and cpu
that your browser uses and bada bing
bada boom you're out in green biome city
baby amazing feature there's more they
got a ton of apps integrated if you're
using whatsapp facebook discord hit up
your bros right in your browser one
button bing bong bang bang you can join
opera gx server they have 500 000
members and you can talk to other people
that have a great taste in what internet
browser they use
some people don't care about it but i do
and that's design this is the
best looking browser if you use my link
in description you get the cool
pewdiepie background which looks so
goddamn good they have a ton of cool
themes as well which i love they also
have live backgrounds for different
games like there's a minecraft one look
at that live background i kind of want
to try that well look at that
a ghost of tsushima one hey but of
course you should only really use mine
oh five stars thanks guys
yeah the only one you need i use opera
even before they reached out to me i
love the music controls well you'll find
when you use it there's a ton of hidden
features and cool stuff that really lets
you customize it the way you want it and
and
have it your way basically while
inferior internet browsers blast you
with a bunch of news that you don't care
about which is super irritating opera gx
games they know what you like and they
give it to you they have a release
calendar for all the next upcoming games
what's that elden ring heck yeah they
also have a random aggregated ones which
honestly i found a ton of great games
today
especially free ones just click on what
consoles you're on and
you're good to go i highly recommend you
guys download opera gx it's free it
supports the channel i've been using
this before they reached out to me for a
long long time i love this browser and i
have absolutely no intention of
switching it's the greatest
it's the greatest love you love your
opera
thank you go download it get the
pewdiepie skit come on you don't have to
get the pewdiepie skin
just download